le rapport annuel de l'unicef le fonds
des nations unies pour l'enfance 14
millions d'enfants meurent chaque année
de maladies de malnutrition dans le
monde
pourtant le rapport 95 laisse apparaître
des signes d'espoir sauf sauf bien sûr
dans les pays comme le rwanda a ragé par
la guerre et dans lesquels la situation
de centaines de milliers d'enfants et
dramatique françoise david et daniel
lévy ils sont environ 115 mille cent
quinze mille enfants rescapés
physiquement la guerre civile mais en
perdition sans parents ni attaches près
d'un tiers d'entre eux a trouvé refuge
en dehors des frontières du rwanda les
autres sont déplacés égaré dans leur
propre pays
on va joindre et les papiers
d'enregistrement des ses enfants avec
les photos essayer de faire des affiches
dans les communes dans les camps etc
pour aider les parents de la famille a
trouvé leurs enfants dans la maison de
possibles on veut absolument garder les
enfants au rwanda avoir des amis
d'accueil et des familles d'accueil
trouver un frère un oncle une tante etc
qui peut prendre en charge les enfants
qui sont absolument orphelins ce sont
les enfants qui ont vraiment témoigner
des actes de violence très très grande
donc c'est pas seulement là la survie de
l'enfant qu'on va sauvegarder ce sont
les cicatrices plutôt psychosocial qui
vont durer et sur laquelle nous devons
travailler pendant les longues années
là dans les grands de demain dans la
mesure où ces camps continuent à exister
je pense qu'il reste à voir comment on
peut introduire la construction de la
paix parce que la paix ne se fait pas
seulement il faut le construire
donc on a commencé également l'unicef
avec le ministère de l'éducation
tout un programme de l'éducation pour la
réconciliation
selon l'unicef il faudra encore au moins
un an de présence des organisations
humanitaires sur place pour remettre
tous ces enfants sur la route de la vie